I'd point out the fact that David zoslav
the CEO of Warner Brothers discovery
which is you know the parent company of
the network I'm talking to you on right
now was paid 250 million dollars last
year a quarter of a billion dollars
that's about the same level as what 10
000 writers are asking him to pay all of
us collectively all right now I don't
want you to be in the street I want them
to pay you fairly that's why I was with
David zazlov last night we were at the
Beverly Hills Hotel and he goes can we
use a non-lethal gas on them I said
David yes but absolutely he goes because
I don't like seeing them outside my
office and I go absolutely I go but but
but David
let's think about this for a second he
was non-lethal I go I understand that he
goes just disorient them
and then I called read hey I texted read
Hastings I said me and David are
thinking about a non-lethal disorienting
gas and he goes LOL and he was with Tad
and he goes lol Having exact same convo
right now